CAITLIN CASSIDY: My
name is Caitlin Cassidy,
and my SuperUROP
project is about helping
teachers give better
feedback on students' code.
So let's take a class at
MIT that's teaching students
how to program in Java.
Teachers already do a great job
of giving students feedback.
So they look at
every student's code
and give them
personalized feedback.
And they also give students
feedback immediately,
so that day or the day after.
So my project is about helping
teachers give better feedback
by changing what they look at.
Typically, when
teachers grade code
they only look at a
student's final code.
And we're investigating
whether if teachers
can see, in addition
to final code,
all the steps that students
took along the way,
whether teachers can give
students better feedback.
So our final interface is
this one in the middle.
So on this left side, we can see
all the students' final code.
So it's as if they
pressed Submit at the end.
The code on the left
is their final code.
But in addition,
we have this code
on the right side over here
that you can see in red,
and that's code that the
students typed and then deleted
at some point in the middle.
So it highlights all the
steps that students took along
the way to get to
the final product.
To test whether this
actually improves feedback,
we ran an experiment
in an MIT classroom.
And we found two metrics
that say that teachers
give longer feedback.
So on average, if
they were looking
at an old interface that
just showed final code,
teachers use about 43 characters
on average to give feedback.
And now, with our
interface, they
give 49 and 1/2 characters.
In addition, before,
about 80% of comments
were above 10 characters,
which is already great.
So less than 10 is maybe if
they said "Good" or "Great job"
as a comment only.
So 80% above that is awesome.
But we increased that to 90%.
So we're seeing
much longer feedback
given by TAs or teachers who
can see a student's code history
as well as their final code.
We also did a
qualitative assessment
about teachers' comments.
So some students were graded
once without the extra code.
So 30% of students
were graded once
without the extra
visualization and once with.
And qualitatively, looking
at all those feedback,
we saw that teachers did
give better comments.
So as one example over
here, if the teachers only
looked at final code, they
just thought that the students
didn't do anything.
But when we can see that
the student actually
did something, shown
in red on the right,
the teacher said,
"Good start, you're
on the right track," which
is much better feedback
for the student and is going
to improve their learning.